what um let's talk about kind of the
international you know kind of economic
situations that are occurring right so
you've got obviously Turkey right you've
got Iran you've got the a low Zimbabwe
never these comfort countries are either
close to or are experiencing
hyperinflation etc you know is there any
time previously that you can think of
where you know there was I don't wanna
say it's widespread because it's still
you know just a handful of countries and
they're kind of the usual suspects type
thing but where economic situations are
chaos to some degree internationally
really drove a change in investor
interest in certain asset classes in the
u.s. not so much in the US but the best
example of hyperinflation ruining a
country was the by Mar Republic in
Germany which extended to kind of vassal
states Austria for a brief time people
were literally going to the zoo and
killing the animals to eat them Wow so
things have gotten a lot worse but
generally speaking when you have when
you have several things in place you
your your risk of that kind of nightmare
economic apocalypse is reduced rather
dramatically the first things is a
relatively free market the United States
likes to say we're a free market we're
not a free market Society we are a
regulated in many instances capture by
corporations of the political system but
still relatively free definitely
compared to counterparts exactly right
so we you know we're the cleanest shirt
in the pile of dirty laundry the other
thing that's really really important is
the rule of law I think actually the
rule of law is the most important when
you can adjudicate your disputes through
a well set up and well respected and
believe
Dinn system that goes a really really
long way towards keeping all those
bogeymen of hyperinflation and
everything out of the picture so it's
not a surprise that when you see those
kinds of economic events and they're
devastating and I I don't want to sound
at all flip these people are really
really suffering and and so but you know
there's a script for not having that
there's kind of a script for having it -
oh and the script for not having it is
not democratic not free institutions no
rule of law and whenever you see a
country that adheres to those those what
I would call that toxic brew the chances
of that kind of thing happening are much
much higher but keep in mind there's
nobody in Venezuela buying anything
other than in u.s. dollars mm-hmm and
that has remained very very stable there
so if you're crazy and want to you know
use their currency well good luck get
your wheelbarrows out yep but again
markets are fascinating things because
what they do is they find a way and and
it's like so just a brief digression I
tend to have a political outlook that is
very different than most people I what I
would say kind of a libertarian and and
I think of things like drug laws I think
drug laws are insane we have all of the
history that shows that they're insane
we have all of the history that shows
they created a much larger mafia and we
have all of the history of showing even
in a great free democracy country like
our own a corruption at the upper levels
of government which is very troubling
look at what they've done in Portugal
they made drugs they decriminalize drugs
15 years ago
guess what's happened drug use has plung
all of the good things and all the kind
of you know things that you could if you
were able to really think about it
happen now does that mean that I
personally take drugs no I don't you
know I I really don't I at a party right
coming home and look at my wife and
saying you have no idea what a Boy Scout
you're married to but but I I think that
this is really interesting right because
it is you know I think most people want
to do what they're told they're not
allowed to do oh right there's an
element of that and so this this work
that you've done on the human psychology
and how they interact with economic
markets and stuff is really interesting
because I think also you know somebody
recently told me they said I think
there's a saying that you know basically
when people can print money they will oh
yeah
right so and so I think that you know
when you look at these you know kind of
hyperinflation countries literally
there's no checks and balances and so
there's usually one person who's kind of
in charge of everything and they print
money yes they do and you know what else
is interesting is I know and I can't
disclose because I you know it's kind of
like I could tell you but I'd have to
kill you when we changed our currency
completely there was a reason for that
mm-hmm some very bad people had Treasury
plates and so in a advanced democracy
like the United States done I mean that
happened to over night mm-hm
making those old plates absolutely
worthless mm-hmm
so when you have a very high functioning
democracy with institutions that have
been around for a long long time those
types of things don't generally happen
and the other thing that I always tell
people and I usually get non Wall Street
people just laughing in my face
and it is people do not really
understand that Wall Street is entirely
based on trust you know get decayed you
know what decay means don't know
right if you get decayed in a trade
you're probably never ever gonna trade
with that guy or woman again ever and
they are effectively boxed out because
everything that we do is done on our
word you know when you get on the phone
you say whatever like the guy buying the
crypto yeah it wasn't on the phone but
if if his counterparty couldn't trust
him well the markets would collapse so I
think that the United States obviously
has probably one of the best functioning
market systems some in Europe especially
interestingly enough Eastern the former
Eastern European states like Estonia etc
they have set up some really cool stuff
and you know like flat tax rates you can
do it all by computer because they had
the opportunity to mmm right and and
that's the other thing that I'm a big
believer in legacy can be a problem
mm-hmm right so if you are a monster
company and all of your software is
circa 1985 getting rid of that and
updating it to 2018 is her clean effort
and so you you definitely you know I
think you and your team are in a
position that's interesting because you
don't have to deal with any of those
situations and you can you can kind of
have best of class right away